okay
well it's gotta be cd right
i don't see it
where is the mate
it's that easy oh now it's over
okay this looks like a very simple one
clearly i should take here and then i
should think
yeah it takes queen bead to check and
before
mates i was only thinking of bishop c5
thereafter
okay this one is pretty standard
all right see this is like like the
queen in six room g8
okay
queen g6
could you one take we need to what's
this a queen d freaking g1 queen g6
keep it one
this is going to be a smothered mate
okay next one 95
and what comes if i
do it wrong like i have an another try
or what
i'm just curious what's
what are the rules okay
clearly it's like 26 24
and my favorite
mate
okay
here i think
queen f7 queen f8 and then mission f5
all right
queen goes here
[Music]
today i think i can i can give two
checks
or remember okay bishop bishop five and
king g and ggs probably protects for the
queen so this doesn't work square f7
makes more sense to me
iq in here
well then bishop takes f5 i'm going
queen f6 okay
i'm just telling you now i'm not going
to be close to the high score here
oh
why was i moving bishop i mean i mean i
knew it was bishop d5 why is it moving
i mean i was thinking of the line bishop
d5 queen d5 f7 then rook h8 then i moved
i moved the move the pawn first for
whatever reason
okay this looks like very simple
what's this like queen g6 should d5 f7
and this one
okay
this is
very inaccurate
very inaccurate bishop 6 is made right
i think it is
okay
and also
some sort of a mating net here maybe
just bishop f6 and bishop g5 and there
is no way to rescue
rescue robber
okay i think this one
okay and anyone is good
okay
yeah rook g6 squad h4
tank
and queen a6 uh
so this is like just g3 queen h4 i think
it takes
here
i think takes
then rook f2
that's mate
that has got to be made
take it
but fv6 was winning right
um that is annoying
that is annoying
i just wanted to make a winning move i
thought the end of it was fe6 rook d7
king f6 all right
okay
clearly
i think that this is the way
and then
oh
this is blood this is this is unfair
this is so unfair
probably just king six and then five
no matter what he does
but
they want me to be more accurate
okay
what name if i play just queen h6 here
i think it's just enough
you